this word is endothermic sender thermic
is a reaction or a process that actually
takes in energy in the form of heat from
its surrounding area when you have
chemical reactions some chemical
reactions need heat to make them go the
products of the reaction have more
energy in them than your starting
materials it will actually suck in this
heat energy and will make it very very
cold so we'll actually see something
that becomes very cold even you can
measure it with a thermometer we can
actually feel it with your hands getting
colder and colder chemists have quite a
limited view of the world
when they're thinking about reactions
they just think about their flasks and
what's going on in their flasks and all
they're interested in is whether heat is
flowing out or heat is flowing in and if
a reaction is endothermic it needs heat
to make it go so heat has to flow in if
you want to keep the temperature the
same if you don't mind about the
temperature the endothermic reaction
will just make things get cold but
because reactions go slower when they're
cold
usually you heat it up to keep the
tension constant so we're actually going
to demonstrate it using a chemical
called ammonium nitrate we're actually
going to set it up connect to the
thermocouple to read how cold it's going
to get so at the moment it's reading
well how cold this lab is at the moment
so we'll see what happens so this stuff
is caked in here so it's a heavy jar
what it means in effect is that you are
breaking strong chemical bonds and
making weak ones and very often we want
to do that the harbour process where you
take nitrogen from the air and make
ammonia for fertilizer is a very good
example of an endothermic reaction you
have to put in more heat then you get by
formation of the chemical bonds okay
the thermocouple is inside right in the
middle of the beaker now I'm just going
to push that down give us a even layer
and the thermocouple is reading the
temperature inside the beaker which is
pretty much the same as out here in the
lab so what's going to happen is I'm
going to add some water to this the
ammonium nitrate is going to dissolve in
the water and what will happen is the
ammonium part and the nitrate part they
split apart and become solute solution
so come on Zin solution so I've got the
water here distilled water it will go in
and we can actually see what happens the
reaction can be something quite boring
like something dissolving what you do is
you break the strong forces between the
ions in the crystal and replace them
with the rather weaker forces between
the water molecules and the ions so some
things when you dissolve them in water
get really cold so you can see that
immediately we get the process of giving
endothermic so what that means is that
it's gone from being about 15 degrees C
to now minus 15 minus 16 so although
it's a sixteen point three here there's
actually a minus symbol there so that's
how cold it's got and in fact if I touch
this I can feel just how cold it's
become the endothermic mixing of nitric
acid and ice was used by Fahrenheit to
find zero or to define 0 on this
temperature scale he wanted to get
something was really really cold so he
mix concentrated nitric acid with snow
and the temperature went straight down
to the temperature which he called zero
degrees Fahrenheit it's just like as if
I'm getting something a bag of peas or
without the freezer
so it's really as cold as that so it's
only been a few seconds and already it's
gone from being at room temperature
right the way down to minus 16